bonjour
greg wolinski granger trois invités de
cette édition de tf1 actualité ouvrant
en bande dessinée cette émission
d'information car pendant le week-end se
tiendra à paris la convention de la
bande dessinée la neuvième du nom
et comme en ce moment dans la bande
dessinée ça bouge
nous avons voulu donner le crayon
aujourd'hui dans cette édition de 13h au
dessinateur trois d'entre eux sont ici
et nous parlerons également tout à
l'heure avec non pas un dessinateur mais
un scénariste de bande dessinée lee falk
qui sera avec nous c'est un américain le
père de mandera qu ils sont avec nous
aujourd'hui illustreront peut-être au
cours de ce journal avec d'autres
desseins le contenu de cette actualité
que nous allons regarder et qui va
commencer en ce vendredi d'octobre par
non plus la mappemonde de granger mais
la carte de guide à rivière et bien
notre été tardive continue hier encore
nous avions 25 degrés à marseille
ajaccio et 23 degrés sur tout le bassin
parisien et enfin depuis deux trois
jours il est en partie quand même
atteint par une certaine détérioration
qui a donné des pluies abondantes
d'abord sur les pyrénées orientales puis
sur les cévennes et sur le sud des alpes
et cette zone pluvieuse plus ou moins
d'y stocker c'est encore aujourd'hui du
nord de la france à la provence et puis
vous voyez une deuxième zone pluvieuse
est en train de se rapprocher du golfe
de gascogne au cours du week-end en
somme cette détérioration va se
poursuivre avec même dimanche un
refroidissement
alors pour demain on peut diviser le
week end ailleurs on peut diviser la
france en deux parties tout l'est de la
france donc des ardennes de l'alsace
jusqu'à la provence ou dans l'ensemble
il y aura vraiment beaucoup de nuages
des pluies peut-être peu importantes sur
la partie nord mais des orages pourront
donner des pluies fortes sur la provence
et jusque sur la corse et des vents
forts en méditerranée est aussi dans la
vallée du rhône ou de la loire et ce
temps va persister également dimanche
alors sur l'autre moitié de la france
c'est bien dès le matin il va pleuvoir
du côté de la bretagne alors que du
bassin parisien aux pyrénées il
commencera d'abord par faire beau et
puis au cours de la journée
ces pluies gagneront l'intérieur de la
france alors que des éclaircies
apparaîtront sur la bretagne mais les
vents se renforceront sur la manche et
sur la botte pour dimanche on va avoir
sur l'ensemble de cette zone ouest de la
france entend beaucoup plus variable
avec des alternance d'éclaircies et de
quelques passages nuageux pouvant donner
des averses averses également qu'on
retrouvera du côté de l'ouest de la
france mais dans l'ensemble des
températures qui vont rester tout de
même un petit peu au dessus de ce qu'on
a normalement à cette époque de l'année
mais tout de même beaucoup plus basse
que tout seul connu ces derniers jours
17 à 16 degrés sur le nord de la france
et seulement 20 à 21 dans le sud
merci la rivière donc tout à l'heure la
bande dessinée au programme de cette
édition de 13 heures au cours de
laquelle nous recevrons également un
auteur jacques duquesne pour son livre
la grande triche au cours de cette
émission de 13 heures également pour la
première fois le nouveau directeur de
l'opéra de paris à la télévision bernard
lefort qui vient d'être nommé qui
succédera en 1980 à rolf lieberman et
qui déjà nous dira quels sont ses
projets en ce qui concerne cette gestion
difficile de l'opéra de paris et ses
projets bien entendu sur le plan dans de
la scène
cela dit l'actualité est tout de suite
avec le pire la nuit dernière après les
résultats de l'autopsié le corps de hans
martin schleyer a été rapatrié en
allemagne fédérale mais en alsace
l'enquète se poursuit ouais c'est de
répondre à une question des terroristes
se trouve-t-il encore sûr
histoire français le point avec
jean-louis burgat l'envoyé spécial de
celsa les gendarmes continuent à
ratisser la région ils fouillent
particulièrement les résidences
secondaires qui se trouve près de la
frontière côté français des résidences
secondaires qui pour beaucoup ont été
achetés ou loués par des allemands pas
de résultat apparemment mais on demeure
persuadé que l'endroit où le commando
s'est caché avec son otage pendant une
bonne partie le des 43 jours se trouve
en france pas loin de la frontière cinq
équipes de la police judiciaire
parisienne sont arrivés à mulhouse hier
soir l analyse minutieusement dans un
premier temps tout le matériel récolté
par les enquêteurs locaux les policiers
fédéraux allemands quant à eux ont
regagné pour la plupart leur pays
je m'étonne de ces rumeurs de désaccord
entre la france et l'allemagne m'a dit
hier soir un haut fonctionnaire français
nos collègues allemands nous ont
vivement remercié en occitan hier soir
en allemagne fédérale autre enquête
celle destinée à savoir comment bader et
ses complices avaient pu mettre au point
un véritable réseau de communications en
morse entre les cellules avec tout un
système de câble prises multiples et de
file de bonnes pour tf1 bernard volker
la chasse aux terroristes se poursuivre
mais pour le moment sans résultat la
police a offert une prime de 100 mille
francs pour chaque terroristes capturés
soit au total 1 million 600 mille francs
cette procédure n'a rien d'exceptionnel
la police allemande offre depuis
toujours des récompenses pour des
informations importantes les allemands
se félicite de la coopération avec des
autorités françaises après la découverte
du corps de monsieur flyers en france
des recherches ont lieu en ce moment
dans plusieurs pays d'europe à la
demande du gouvernement allemand mais il
est probable que les assassins de
monsieur flyers avaient prévu cela et
qu'ils resteront cachés pendant un bon
moment
le ministre de la justice du
bade-würtemberg a démissionné hier à la
suite du suicide de andreas baader
on a appris vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure que les détenus avaient mis au
point un système de communications en
morse l'enquète n'a pas non plus permis
pour le moment de savoir comment bader
heras peu s'était procuré des révolvers
les obsèques de monsieur flyers auront
lieu mardi une cérémonie nationale est
prévue c'est monsieur chez le président
de la république fédérale allemande qui
prononcera l'éloge funèbre du disparu
andreas baader quant à lui et ses deux
amis seront ils
mais côte à côte à stuttgart jeudi
prochain on a enfin appris tout à
l'heure que bader avait demandé un
secrétaire d'état de venir lui rendre
visite la semaine dernière pour une
révélation importante sachant que bader
avait un revolver en se demandent
maintenant s'ils n'avaient pas
l'intention d'assassiner ce représentant
de l'état et de se suicider ensuite on a
tout ce qu'on peut dire pour le moment
à noter sur la sphère de la lutte contre
le terrorisme un reportage publié
aujourd'hui par le journal le meilleur
24 personnalités répondent à la question
faut-il abattre les terroristes à bout
portant
parmi les réactions nombreuses à cette
affaire celle de françois mitterrand
c'est à sofia où il répondait à
l'invitation du secrétaire général du
parti communiste bulgare que le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste a
commenté la sphère schleyer avec bruno
masure l'envoyé spécial de telles
affaires terroristes en allemagne n'est
pas une affaire terroriste allemande
c'est une affaire qui tient aux normes
même de la civilisation occidentale
vous observerez que ce qui pousse la
révolte jusqu au nihilisme jusqu'à la
barbarie du nihilisme sont généralement
issus des milieux de la bourgeoisie
parfois de la haute bourgeoisie
on pourrait dire même si la réponse
qu'ils apportent ne peut nous convenir
que c'est une façon de s'opposer
spirituellement aux échecs spirituel aux
valeurs même de l'occident
c'est un problème qu'on doit se poser
pour nous mêmes mais qui doit être posée
encore davantage dans les couches
dirigeantes celles qui produisent
essentiellement ce phénomène et qui
ayant privé notre civilisation de toute
forme d'idéal d'objectifs grandiose de
vastes perspectives fabrique même ce
type d'opposition
monsieur mitterrand si l'anc est prouvé
que l'on a quelque peu aidé andreas
baader à se suicider est ce que vous
condamnent auriez ce geste des autorités
allemandes
oui c'est une hypothèse je ne sais rien
de cette enquête
mais si j'accepte la question telle que
vous la poser je vous répondrai qu'on
défend le droit par le droit et donc je
condamnerai tout
action toute initiative qui ne
respecteraient pas le principe du droit
une un pays civilisé ne peut se défendre
contre le terrorisme que si d'une part
il est sans complaisance pour ce
terrorisme s'il marque dans ses lois et
danser à classe sévérité nécessaire mais
s'il inscrit cette sévérité dans le
cadre du droit des gens on ne peut pas
manquer aux droits des gens lorsqu on
est civilisés
ou bien là c'est qu'on subit la
contagion de barbares sur le plan
politique françois mitterrand a déclaré
que les socialistes français entendent
que la gauche l'emportent mais qu'ils ne
peuvent se porter garant de tout le
monde
à défaut pour l'instant de pouvoir
assurer la victoire de la gauche entière
a dit françois mitterrand les
socialistes veulent assurer la victoire
du ps jacques chirac était hier à metz
après une tournée de deux jours dans le
département de la moselle pour le
président du rpr aucune solution à nos
problèmes ne pourrait venir d'une
inspiration dit social démocratie qui
combinerait un peu de libéralisme mou
avec un peu de socialisme tiède
il faut a dit jacques chirac une volonté
politique fermement défini suite et fin
du sondage informe ifop sur les
électeurs récalcitrants qui peuvent tout
changer en 78 15 % des communistes
déclarent refuser tout report de voix
sur le ps au second tour
à la question qui va gagner en mars aux
78 20 % répondre la majorité 38%
l'opposition mais le pourcentage le plus
important quarante deux pour cent ne se
prononcent pas encore le parti
républicain a donné ce matin une
première liste de 104 noms des candidats
aux législatives de 118 sur les 300 qui
se présenteront avec l'investiture du p
r parmi ces 104 noms 71 nouveaux
candidats seulement quatre femmes et une
moyenne d'âge de 40 ans seconde journée
des entretiens de raymond barre helmut
schmidt les deux hommes devaient
aujourd'hui aborder les problèmes
économiques
la reprise en france est entrée
directement liés à la relance en
allemagne fédérale
les allemands et n étant nos principaux
clients gérard saint paul monsieur
raymond barre est en ce moment en route
pour paris après une visite officielle
de moins de 24 heures hier soir au cours
du dîner offert par le chansonnier
schmidt
monsieur bart a félicité son hôte pour
son courage et sa fermeté et a dit c'est
la liberté qui gagne ce matin le premier
ministre a reçu les ministre allemand
des finances de l'économie
et des armées pour une série
d'entretiens se faisait problème
particulier avec monsieur apple que vous
voyez ici venise des finances il a été
question de la construction navale des
textiles des marchés extérieurs
tout cela dans la perspective d'un
ralentissement de la croissance des pays
industrialisés
avant son départ monsieur bart a dit
nous avons fait le point clairement sur
la nécessité de la lutte contre
l'inflation
le premier ministre considère que le
bilan de son voyage est positif en ce
qui concerne l'économie
il a simplement parlé d'un effort qui
sera fait en vue de l'harmonisation des
politiques à court terme de la france et
de l'allemagne
un effort dont on parle à chaque réunion
franco allemande mais qui a du mal
semble-t-il à se traduire dans la
réalité
merci d'un voltaire on apprend l'instant
deux prochains déplacements du chef de
l'état en province le 25 novembre le 25
octobre valéry giscard d'estaing
inaugurera le musée de la renaissance
d'ecouen et le 7 novembre
il se rendra à brest pour une visite à
la marine nationale
valéry giscard d'estaing montera à bord
de la jeanne est là s'adressera aux
élèves officiers
hier c'est devant plus de 1000
architectes que le président de la
république annoncé huit mesures
concernant l' architecture qui auront
pour effet d'améliorer le cadre de vie
des français mesures annoncées lors de
la séance de clôture du symposium pour
une politique de l'architecturé organisé
par l'académie d'architecturé un
organisme de réflexion qui déplore que
l'on confond trop souvent ceux qui
commandent et ceux qui exécutent les
constructions un enquête de robert vers
l'est
l'harmonie d'une ville c'est très
précieux
elle doit être gérée d'une manière
attentive calcul et le bien-être de ceux
qui évoluent dans un espace
architectural qui a du coeur est ainsi
bien servi qu'ils agissent vieilles
demeures où de nouveaux immeubles qu'on
disait audacieux il y a encore quelques
années
l'art urbain doit d'être gérés dans le
temps dans sa globalité et non pas d'une
manière fractionnée kick ass esthétique
cette harmonie a dans le passé toujours
été voulue au temps des monarchies ou
des gouvernements à notre époque en
prend aux bouleversements une politique
harmonieuse de l' architecture doit
encore être pratiquées
on considère trop souvent l'urbanisme
comme un simple problème foncier
vu sous l'angle fiscal et administratif
n'est ce pas qui on dit ensuite on
pourra parachuter des shows dessus c'est
pas bon ça parce que d'une part il ya un
certain nombre de constructeurs qui font
des choses préfabriqués on leur dit
voilà un terrain qui est à découper
comme un gâteau vous mettez ce que vous
voulez là dessus comment voulez-vous qui
est une harmonie larchitecture les
questions d'urbanisme on en parle de
plus en plus mais en pleurant un peu
trop sur le passé s'est construit
actuellement aussi joliment tavan
attention non non j'ai vu patty est
bonne celle qui est en face est ce que
ça veut dire que actuellement on ne peut
plus construire bien pourrait seulement
quoi tu talent de l'argent je comprends
cette contents d'habiter dans une
vieille belle maison
bah moi ça m'embêterait un demande aller
puisqu'il ya julie il ya cinquante ans
que je suis ici alors et puis ça fait
cinquante ans que cet homme égale et
c'est toujours par l'histoire de votre
maison non non non
l'académie d'architecturé dont les
origines remontent à colbert se trouvent
place des vosges à paris
cette place admirable créé sous henri iv
il possède une façade mansart le mot
architecte est cité pour la première
fois à l'époque du grand philibert
delorme l'un des bâtisseurs du louvre le
balcon sur cette gravure et celui sur
lequel se tenait louis xiii face à la
place d'armes qui était la place des
vosges c'était ce qu'il voyait rien n'a
changé ici les architectes illustres qui
furent des président de l'académie
visconti labrouste garnier pâle tard
celui des halles quand on parle et qu'on
ne voit jamais
les architectes ont bon dos qu'on ne les
oublie pas mais que finalement il faut
également voir les gens qui commandent
oui bien sûr parce que les architectes
sont des éléments du maillon et sa part
très haut ça parle de la maîtrise
d'ouvre à des décideurs des hommes
politiques qui ont certainement de très
bonnes intentions au départ qui sont
traduites quelquefois par
l'administration qui a également de très
bonnes intentions mais qui ne comprend
pas toujours la globalité de l'effet
créatif eux doivent pouvoir bien vivre
demain michel d'ornano a présenté hier
aux députés le budget de la culture
budget en augmentation de 18 5% par
rapport à l'an dernier c'est la
progression la plus importante depuis
cinq ans pour le ministre la culture ne
saurait être l'apanage de la capitale et
de quelques rares métropole c'est pour
cela que des efforts seront faits sur le
plan de la décentralisation les
priorités de ce budget les bibliothèques
les centres dramatiques et les musées
qu' il n'y a pas de priorité pour l'art
lyrique dans ce budget bernard lefort la
priorité pour la l'erika était donné je
crois il ya quelques années on ne peut
pas demander que chaque année la
priorité soit donnée à la lyrique je
pense que dans le cadre d'un budget qui
reste modeste il est juste que chaque
discipline culturelle bénéficient et à
tour de rôle des efforts et l'opéra a
bénéficié il y a six ou sept ans d'un
effort particulier qui a permis à
monsieur lieberman des réalisations de
haut niveau je pense que nous pouvons
partir sur un budget de référence qui
existe maintenant on ne le dira jamais
qu'on a assez je pense que
raisonnablement on peut exploiter cette
maison dans le cadre de son budget
actuel suivant naturellement l'inflation
mais ça me paraît être un budget
raisonnable compte tenu de ce que
reçoivent des théâtres comme le covent
garden à londres où la scala de milan
nous ne sommes pas désavantager bien
bernard lefort vous venez d'être nommé
directeur de l'opéra vous prendrez vos
fonctions en 1980 c'est un peu loin mais
enfin les saisons se préparer on prépare
à peu près deux ans à l'avancé une
saison lyrique qu'elle sera disent on
veut votre maître mot pour rolf
liebermann s'était rendre le prestige à
l'opéra de paris vous qu'est ce que ce
sera je ne peux pas dire rendre son
festif puisque il la retrouve est
justement grâce à ces lieberman par
conséquent pour moi le maître mot sera
l'opéra au chanteur français
je vais faire porter mon effort dès
demain sur la formation d'une nouvelle
génération de chanteurs français
je pense que d'ici quelques jours
quelques semaines plus tard des mesures
très spectaculaire vont être annoncées
j'ai devant moi
six ans si j'avais 10 ans je dirais dans
dix ans leur répertoire courant de
l'opéra sera tenu par des chanteurs
français et les chanteurs étrangers
invités seront des événements d
exception je n'ai que six ans ce n'est
pas suffisant pour arriver au but mais
c'est suffisant pour mettre la machine
en route et je pense que il y a là une
action à faire elle n'était pas
prioritaire
si j'étais arrivé au palais garnier ou
si j'étais resté et si vous assurez 2 un
tirage de passage que j ai fait j'aurais
choisi la solution de rolf liebermann la
solution était de rendre à paris sans
prestige est le seul moyen de le lui
rendre était celui qui l'a employé c'est
à dire de faire venir tout ce qu'il y
avait deux célèbres et de qualité dans
le monde
deux autres choses bernard lefort la
première concerne la gestion de perrin
le père a été
gérable est ce qu'avec tout ce qu'il
comporte des éléments une compagnie
ballet une troupe d'opéra est ce que on
peut gérer cette grande maison
la gestion de l'opéra est extrêmement
complexe
d'abord c'est une grande entreprise
comme tout une entreprise qui emploie
plus de 1000 personnes c'est déjà une
entreprise considérable qui a géré un
budget très conséquent il est très
complexe parce qu'il s'éparpille dans
des disciplines extrêmement différentes
c'est la raison pour laquelle je crois
que la mise en place d'une
administration plus fonctionnel avec la
nomination d'un secrétaire général
aux côtés des administrateurs financiers
déjà présents et destiné à décharger
tout de suite rolf liebermann les mois
par la suite de charges administratives
beaucoup trop lourde
je crois que c'est une solution
raisonnable et je suis persuadé pour ma
part que je serai considérablement aidé
dans la gestion de cette maison par le
fait de partager avec secrétaire général
ces lourdes charges
la deuxième chose concerne un peu la
télévision aussi le grand public qui se
demandent à carpentras ou à narbonne
pourquoi il a payé dans ses impôts une
part de la vie de l'opéra de paris
la télévision parce que on se demande
pourquoi on n'en voit pas plus souvent
des créations de l'opéra de paris
pourrait grande diffusion et puis disons
aussi ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens de
payer leur place trois problèmes
différents écoutez je crois que on a
pris conscience de la nécessité absolue
de ce que tous les spectacles de l'opéra
soit diffusée et proposer aux 53
millions de français on a pris
conscience d'abord il faut s'en
féliciter au niveau du personnel des
personnels de l'opéra on a pris
confiance au niveau des directions de
trois chaînes nationales et les
directives qui avait été donné dans ce
sens il y a plusieurs mois par le
gouvernement et par le président la
république quand je croise était pour
l'instant bien suivi et les choses sont
bien engagées il va falloir maintenant
les intensifier
l'opéra de paris est régulièrement déjà
retransmis le festival d'aix que je
dirige actuellement vois tous ces
spectacles lyriques retransmis également
c'est déjà une activité considérable et
ce qui me moi me réjouis beaucoup c'est
que nous voyons nous savons par les
sondages que les téléspectateurs pour
les spectacles et les risques augmentent
chaque année réduction du prix des
places envisageable à la salle garnier
réduction du prix des places sur les
bases normales je ne pense pas mais
accès aux collectivités par le moyen de
prix spéciaux
je l'espère en tout cas à partir du 25
on verra à la salle favart paris l'une
des créations du festival d'aix dont
bernard le fera assure également la
direction ce sera la traviata mais nous
y reviendrons la semaine prochaine la
suite de l'actualité en bretagne
nouvelle flambée d'attentats à brest
c'est un immeuble de la sécurité
militaire et une cuve à mazout qui ont
été endommagées à guingamp c'est la
recette des finances qui était visé et à
tréveneuc le centre d'action sociale de
la police les attentats ne sont pas
revendiqués
ce matin à paris vers 10h15 avenue
victor hugo un homme a été tué par une
explosion dont on ignore toujours les
cause une enquête pour nous par claude
bertrand l'explosion s'est produite dans
la cour intérieure de cet immeuble de la
rue victor hugo vers 10h15 cet attentat
à la bombe n'a pas encore été
revendiquées visaient en fait les locaux
d'une société de location de bureaux
situé au troisième étage de l'immeuble
une bombe dissimulée dans une valise
avait été déposée devant la porte de la
société dans le courant de la matinée
jugeant le colis suspect un coursier qui
passait par là avait décidé de la
descendre dans le hall c'est un art
vivant dans la cour intérieure que la
bombe a explosé
le malheureux coursier a été tué sur le
coup
à oklahoma city aux états unis un hôtel
de 27 étages qui n'avait plus assez de
clients était démolie d'un seul coup par
une explosion mise au point par une
équipe d'experts en démolition des
images assez exceptionnel
ben j'ai effectivement assez étonnante
on se demande ce qui doit arriver en cas
d'explosion pareil dans les immeubles
d'à côté si les lézardes ne sont pas en
train de craquer tous les sadi qui
tombent les états unis pour revenir chez
nous dunkerque 1940 la grande triche
c'est un roman de jacques duquesne aux
éditions grasset jacques duquesne quitte
un confrère journaliste et quand on lit
votre livre dunkerque 1940 vous le guide
dès le départ c'est un roman de lancer
des cris sur la couverture salle est
effectivement cette histoire de justin
mais c'est aussi un grand reportage
aiguë ken preuve c'est un roman c'est
vraiment un roman avec des histoires
très diverses qui se mêlent et qui
s'entremêlent mais c'est aussi c'est
vrai une partie autobiographique à une
partie de souvenirs inscrivait parce que
je guettais moi je veux dire j'étais
j'avais 10 ans là on a toujours raconté
les guerre vue par ceux qui les ont
faites ne serai jamais du point de vue
d'un gosse de 10 ans qui voit un monde
s'écroule et enfin vraiment s'écrouler
comme la tour qu'on vient de voir sur
ces images précisément votre pari
croyait à un tas de choses c'est
l'histoire d'une grande désillusion
finalement qu'il croyait à un trait de
choses du monde des adultes est
finalement bon le passage de l'enfance
au monde adulte c'est toujours une
grande désillusion dans un certain sens
mais pour lui ça se passe en quelques
jours parce qu'en quelques jours là il
ya un état de crise alors ça aurait pu
l'être dunkerque en 1940 ce replay
n'importe quoi est ce pas chaque état de
crise je crois révèle les gens et révèle
que la vie dans un certain sens c'est
une grande triche biya le gosse de
disant qu'ils voient la guerre à
laquelle il jouait lorsqu'il n'y avait
pas la guerre oui mais il était très
content lui qui est la guerre quand là
quand on annonce la guerre en 1939 il
est très content parce qu'ils se dit
d'abord j'ai entendu tellement ce que
nous ont raconté les anciens ceux qui
ont fait une 914 maintenant moi je
pourrais un compte à mon tour marqué
c'est ce qui m'a d'ailleurs mais en même
temps on n'est ce pas il se dit lui que
qui va voir des choses qui va participer
des choses mais alors ça correspond pas
du tout à tout son imagerie héroïque à
toutes les bandes dessinées qui à
l'époque était pas du tout caricatural
mais qui était au contraire très comme
ça qu'ils mettaient qui magnifiait à
certains efforts il ya eu des histoires
de la garde 14 avant de décider par
exemple n'est ce pas qui serait illizi
aujourd'hui ou qui nous feraient tous
éclaté de rire et ce petit gros cela lui
se rend compte de ça en met vraiment en
quelques jours alors c c'est terrible
pour lui alors heureusement il ya en
contrepoint dans cette histoire à notre
personnage qui est un adulte qui est un
officier excédera qui lui est un
personnage sans illusion départ puis qui
finalement lui les événements la même
plutôt à se demander s'il faut pas avoir
un peu d'illusions et un peu de principe
parce qu'au fond c'est le lieutenant
voilà une gare attendu toute façon c'est
une guerre qui devait avoir lieu après
tout on va la saisir au vol cette galles
n'est pas si mauvaise que ça à ses
débuts à ruby y compris par le
lieutenant qui induit que qui va se
faire comme c'est un set à l'arrivée
c'est un arriviste impôts optique et met
en face à la révise quand même alors il
se dit qu'il va d'abord aller un peu sur
le front histoire récolté une belle
décoration ensuite il sera affecté dans
les états majeure n'est ce pas puis
manque de pot c'est si vous voulez ça se
passe pas comme il avait prévu ça se
passe pour personne comme c'était prévu
alors c'est dramatique pour tout le
monde et tout le monde a le sentiment
d'une triche terrible et une grande
désillusion
la grande triche dunkerque en culottes
courtes
un roman passionnant dunkerque 1940
si et jacques duquesne aux éditions
grâce bien je vais voir ce qu'ont signé
maintenant au dessinateur de bd puisque
vous le savez je voulais dit tout à
l'heure
le week-end sera marqué à paris à
l'espace cardin par cette 9e convention
de la bande dessinée vous avez écouté
voilà ce qui ce qui s'est passé pendant
le journal je vous ai vus prendre des
tas de petites notes c'est votre façon
de procéder habituellement vous l'avez
mise par terre ou après il ya une grande
fille sur laquelle vous ai vu marquer
des phrases prononcées par que le pire à
roues par mois ou par certains qui
passait dans le journal
giscard monte sur la jeanne les
gendarmes ratissent les résidences
secondaires
mitterrand du monde commente la sphère
schleyer aux bulgares cetera chirac pas
de libéralisme mou c'est votre façon de
procéder quand vous avez à faire un
dessin vous noté plusieurs idées ou
encore si vous ne me considérais pas
comme un journaliste parce que je
travaille comme n'importe quel
journaliste prend des notes et après je
je choisis parmi tous les événements
celui qui me paraît le plus fort alors
le plus fort c'est celui que vous
choisissez la première phrase que vous
avez noté du reste houba d'air at il
trouvé un revolver alors c'est sans
commentaire il suffit de regarder de
près ce cas destinée vol à skis quant à
grands jets qui est un habitué de tf1
l'inspiration est venue à quel moment là
sur une phrase donnée sur un évènement
donné du journal oui c'est un dessin sur
le thème des prisonniers politiques et
prisonniers politiques
alors ça ne s'explique pas non plus ça
se regarde
granger vous le connaissez c'est lui qui
illustre bien souvent que nos séquences
dans tf1 actualité le soir ou à 13
heures et puis alors greg
là encore il s'agit de violences oui la
fameuse violence toujours présente dans
la bande dessinée
je dirais que au contraire de voilà ce
qui moi je suis pas journaliste du tout
je suis un raconteur de petites
histoires en bande dessinée la vraie
bande dessinée gens que je repère
toujours de ma personne j'ai pas de
l'actualité mais mes personnages gens
ont tendance comme tous les personnages
de bande dessinée maintenant à se
conduire comme des gens de l'actualité
il ya un phénomène de mimétisme je crois
dans la bande dessinée qui se produit
actuellement en tout cas voici comment
expliquez vous cette explosion de la
bande dessinée parce que si on regarde
un peu ce qui s'est passé cette année on
s'aperçoit que en dehors des
journalistes qui continuent leur travail
de journaliste en dessinant il ya eu une
véritable explosion de nouvelles revues
on en est au numéro de bd et puis en
plus de ça il y en a des tas d'autres de
science fiction et autres commandes
commence expliquer cette évolution de la
bd c'est pas une évolution je prends
l'explosion oui c'est un phénomène de
mode pas toujours justifiées parce qu'il
faut bien penser que dans la bd
actuellement il ya 99% de choses qui
sont pas bonnes mais
il ya un bien grand public c'est certain
nous essayons de faire le 1 % qui est
beau enfin % quévillon on le retrouvera
à l'espace cardin dimanche au cours de
cette 9e convention de la bande dessinée
alors il y aura bien sûr les
dessinateurs millions aussi quelques
scénaristes et nous avons la joie
d'accueillir aujourd'hui sur ce plateau
un scénariste qui est le père d'un
personnage extraordinaire que hockey
depuis de longues années
lee falk qui est le père de demandera
qu'on peut lire dur est en ce moment
dans notre confrère fonds soir une bande
dessinée sûrement drac que vous voyez en
ce moment or dit inquiète de mangue
black men
comment avez vous de créer mon drac et
quand j'étais 19e très jeune quand vous
aviez 19 ans oui et comment vous étiez
déjà passionné par la bande dessinée et
l'ua de dire interest fort de deux
vidéos 17 voix des domaines
by one you waiting quels étaient les
principales bande dessinée comme vous
aviez 19 ans pour les gogos
je ne sais pas mais en france on aime
parler que deux heures il n'y a pas de
dégâts seigneur c'est fini mat leur part
de you explain the interest of the
people now faut de billy comment
expliquez-vous aujourd'hui l'intérêt des
gens pour la bande dessinée 1 18 de ses
mines terrestres states est ce que c'est
le même intérêt aux états unis un
thurman dans tout le monde mais j'ai
fait mendrika aussi aux fantômes oui et
c'est dans 40 pays moubarak est le
fantôme passe dans 40 pays et actuel
jacques sûr on m'a dit de moyenne
mondiale devrait à 100 millions de
lecteurs chaque jour pour mon bac en
tout cas liffol que sera aussi à cette
convention de la bande dessinée je vous
le rappelle demain et après demain pour
tous ceux qui aiment ça à l'espace
cardin tout de suite à l'espace
boursiers peut-être sonné tendront oui
vous il ya l'espace boursiers se passe
beaucoup de choses on se bouscule
beaucoup entre les groupes il ya
beaucoup d'affaires et les valeurs
françaises sont toutes en hausse
sensible comme vous pouvez le voir avec
les indicateurs de tendance pourtant le
dollar baisse de nouveau ce matin mais
le calme revient cependant sur les
marchés des changes où l'on si l'on
excepte l'inquiétude qui se manifeste
sur la livre sterling à quelques jours
de la présentation du budget d'automne
au parlement britannique
ce budget prévoit en effet quelques
mesures de relance qui font craindre à
tort ou à raison une reprise de
l'inflation
le malheur des uns faisant parfois le
bonheur des autres il semble que l'on
observe aujourd'hui un peu plus d'achats
de valeurs françaises pour compte
britannique mais ce ne sont pas les
seuls les allemands aussi achète et même
les américains semble-t-il s'intéresse
au marché parce qu'ils nous donnent un
certain nombre de hausse
d'autant qu'en ce début de mois boursier
où chacun peut disposer d'une nouvelle
période de crédit la tentation d'achat
en est que plus grande ce qui ce qui
justifie d'ailleurs le prix de l'argent
un peu plus élevés pour ces achats 5% le
taux des records aujourd'hui
contre 2 3 4% le mois dernier les
décalages en hausse sont donc nombreux
et les exceptions à ces rares comme
celle des ciments lafarge dont les
résultats au 30 juin
il est vrai ne sont pas formidables mais
c'est une grande majorité de hausse qui
se dégage un petit peu partout avec deux
points forts sur le matériel électrique
qui bénéficient d'achats suivi depuis
plusieurs jours vous en voyez ici
quelques exemples ainsi que elle savait
que elf aquitaine et sow parmi les
valeurs pétrolières le même la compagnie
française des pétroles à monter
sensiblement aujourd'hui et je peux même
vous donner quelques hausses sensibles
par ailleurs la lyonnaise des eaux +23
là et faro et on n'en passerait on ne
pourrait en énumérer beaucoup le marché
de l'or est lui-même un petit peu mieux
orientées aujourd'hui 160 $ 95 l'once
d'or fin ce matin à londres la barre
gagne 150 francs à 25 1425 le lingot 170
francs alors que le napoléon à 247
despair 30 centimes les valeurs
étrangères sont un petit peu mieux
orientées aujourd'hui wall street était
lui même mieux orienté hier soir là
aussi un point fort avec les pétrolières
étrangères tandis que les mines d'or
sont diversement traités et le quatre et
demi pour 173 à 660 50 gagne 2 francs
alors que la caisse nationale de
l'énergie
elle perd 1 franc une excellente séance
par par conséquent pour cette fin de
semaine ici la bourse de paris à vous
imovie et bien vous souhaiter à toutes
et à tous une excellente après-midi un
excellent week-end nous nous retrouvons
dimanche 12h30 dans mon appétit au
revoir